تمام
انا على الهواء كده
معلش مساء الخير مره تانيه احنا اسفين
يعني بدانا ثم انقطع البث لاي سبب لا
اعلمه انما اتمنى تكون حضراتكم ما زلتم
تتابعونا يعني انا كنت برد على السؤال احد
اصدقائنا استاذنوا ان يعيد السؤال اذا كان
ما زال قائما يعني
اخونا
عميد بيقول كيف يعكس اعاده اندماج بشار
الاسد في المحيط العربي
على استراتيجيات هذه الدول في التعامل مع
الصراعات المستمره وما هي الاثار المحتمله
على التوازن القوى في الشرق الاوسط السؤال
يعني يعني لوس لديفاين يعني لو لو يكون
السؤال يعني
لكن اذا ما كانش فيه فرصه ان انت تعيد
صياغه السؤال
فانا اقدر اقول لك انه الهدف كله ان هم
عندهم اسباب ضاغطه دفعتهم الى المصالحه مع
بشار الاسد انا ما بقولش مع سوريا ليه
لانه هو في خلافات ما هو ما كانوش كانوا
شايفين ان سوريا ديت المفروض يعني هم
كانوا يعني في ناس مش عاوزين يتعاملوا مع
بشار الاسد وعاوزين يتعاملوا مع المعارضه
كان في ناس شايفين ان لابد ان تكون هناك
منطقه حكم ذاتي بل ودوله مستقره للكورد
مثلا في شمال سوريا في الجامعات المسلحه
في الشمال اللي مكانتش بتعترف او ما زالت
لا تعترف شر انا بتكلم على الحكومه
السوريه الدول العربيه اللي طبعت اللي هي
مجموعه الدول العربيه اللي طبعت في دول
عندها شروط وفي دول رافده زي قطر شايفه
انه من غير المجدي مقاطعات بشار الاسد
وانه اذا كانت هناك خلافات يجب
التطبيع معهم مش بمعنى ما فات قد مات ولكن
بمعنى ان نفتح القنوات للتفاهم للتفاهم
على امور كثيره
ملف المخدرات اللي كان احد الاصدقاء
بيتكلم عليه ده واحد منهم لكن في ملفات
تانيه كتيره عاوزين نقعد مع بشار الاسد
ونحسمها عندنا مصالح كتيره عاوزين نجلس
ونقول له اهم مشكله شاغله الدول المجاوره
اهم المشكله
المشاكل بخلاف مشكله المخدرات واحد ان انا
عندي ملايين اللاجئين الموجودين ملايين
اللاجئين دول مش كلهم مرحب بيهم لان هم مش
كلهم مهندسين واطباء وعلماء في او حتى
تجار واصحاب رؤوس اموال بعضهم يعني ناس
بسيطه هربت من اتون الحرب وهي تمثل بعد
سنوات عبء على هذه الدول حتى الدول اللي
هي كانت ظروفها معقوله زي تركيا
دلوقتي اهم
اورج او اهم حافز لهذه الدول ان هم
يتفاوضوا مع بشار الاسد بحيث انه تفتح
الابواب لعوده هؤلاء اللاجئين حتى تخف
الضغوط عن هذه الدول بقطع النظر عن مدى
رضا هؤلاء اللاجئين عن هذه العوده
ده واحد اتنين انه يقلق جدا الدول العربيه
بعد فتره هي قطعت العلاقات معه احد اهم
الاسباب لقطع العلاقات معاه ومحاوله
الاطاحه به هو علاقته
بالايران
الدول الخليجيه كان عدوها الرئيسي هو
ايران ما زالت حتى بعد الانفراجه في
العلاقات مع ايران ايران الانفراجه دي
معناه ان احنا نفتح الباب للتفاوض مش
معناه ان احنا بقينا حبايب واصبحنا هنعرف
احد وسائل
محاصره النفوذ الايراني هو التطبيعي مع
الاسد اذا طبعه مع الاسد زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم في الحلقه اللي كنا بنتكلم عليها
ان هو برضو في يوم من الايام لازم هيبقى
في عمليه اعاده اعمار في سوريا اذا هم
شاركوا في اعاده الاعمار هيستفيدوا امرين
واحد ان هيكون لهم نفوذ في سوريا فيقدر
انه انا اساعد في اعاده الاعمار وبالتالي
ليا راي فيه تشكيل العمليه السياسيه او
اصلاح ما هي يعني انهاء الازمه السوريه ده
هيمر بسنين طويله جدا يكون لهم راي يتاخد
مصالحهم لا